esta área de residencial se encuentra en
una localidad conocida como cool bag y
no está a 15 km del centro de la
población de mykolaiv que es considerada
un gran escudo para proteger a la ciudad
violeta del avance de las tropas
terrestres rusas aquí hasta este lugar
llegaron las tropas rusas hasta el 6 de
marzo a un 1.5 kilómetros de aquí las
tropas ucranianas lograron capturar
lanzacohetes y también recuperaron un
aeropuerto una fábrica y varias calles
que estuvieron en su control en este
bloque residencial cayeron varias bombas
y cohetes algunos apartamentos quedaron
destruidos aunque afortunadamente no
hubo fallecidos sin embargo se siguen
sintiendo bombardeos en la distancia y
nos cuentan los habitantes que al menos
cinco veces al día suenan las alarmas y
muchos de los que se quedaron aquí
especialmente personas mayores pasan la
mayor parte del tiempo en refugios
subterráneos hemos encontrado a la
localidad de mi calor más militarizada
que antes y también hemos sentido como
muchas más personas a nava a la ciudad a
pesar de que las tropas rusas han sido
obligadas a retroceder a mayor distancia
y actualmente se encuentran a 50 km